morgan wallen has gone on camera for the
first time after being caught using a
racial slur
since he did he's been dropped by major
radio stations across the country
and his record label contract has been
suspended
yeah morgan is apologizing and says he's
accepted invitations to meet with
various black
organizations my words matter
my work can truly hurt a person and at
my core that's not what i'm okay with
this week i heard firsthand some
personal stories from black people
that honestly shook me and i know what
i'm going through this week doesn't even
compare to some of the trials i heard
about from them
i came away from those discussions with
a deep appreciation for them
and a clearer understanding of the
weight of my words
i wish the circumstances were different
for me to learn these things but
i'm also glad it started the process for
me to do so
i've got many more things to learn but i
already know that i don't want to add to
any division
this week was a big lesson that
sometimes we can do just that
without even knowing it our actions
matter our words matter
and i just want to encourage anyone
watching to please learn from my mistake
there's no reason to downplay what i did
it matters and please know i'm carefully
choosing my next steps in repair
i want to end this update hopefully on a
more positive note
since that video was taken i've been
sober for nine days
it's not all that long of a time but
it's enough to know the man
in that video is not the man that i'm
trying to be
i've had this week to think about times
when i'm sober and i'm really proud of
who i am and my actions for most for the
most part in those moments
when i look on the times that i'm not it
seems to be where the majority of my
mistakes are made
so i decided to go off the grid for a
little while and get used to making good
decisions
all right lots of comments about this so
paul says too much consequence for his
actions not right but shouldn't destroy
a life
uh cuesta's apology is not enough his
career is over joey says he's full of
beep
he's only sorry that he's facing
consequences he's clearly reading a
script if someone else mentions that
melissa says morgan looks like he's
reading something
yeah he's obviously wrote down what he
wants to say but yeah what do you think
about him
not doing it off the cuff like obviously
pre-planning what he wanted to say
he doesn't seem like the type of person
that can just speak off the cuff and not
say something controversial
like this is the same guy that was
kissing girls in a bar during a global
pandemic
and and ruined a really important snl
appearance
and then came back and anyway i just
think
he had to write a script and mind you he
didn't write it it was his team who
wrote it
um and he sat there and the fact that
he's like even scrolling through it
i think that's just so that his core
fans or whoever
looks at it and goes oh he doesn't feel
that way he's not really saying the
n-word is
is wrong that's my take on it um because
we see that all the time people making
apologies the ones that are sincere
they care very much about you feeling
like it's sincere
other people who purposely kind of just
make it very dismissive in that way i
think it's just sending a message of
like i don't really believe what i'm
saying for people who are defending him
um i don't know this is one of those
things that i just
i understand it on two sides like i
understand you know you're
you're drunk and you know maybe you have
substance abuse issues
you know maybe you're doing and saying a
lot of things he's kind of has this
reputation for being a bad boy
um he does a lot of different things all
the time he's in hot water a lot he's
young
but i don't know i don't think that like
you needed talk to black leaders and
black people to know that the n word is
offensive
i have this conversation i had a friend
you know say the r word
randomly like and i'm like you know
that's offensive right
and it was just the two of us and i'm
like if i don't nip it in the bud with
you one-on-one you're gonna go say it
out in the world and i need to be
telling you that the r word is a word
you don't use and
we had a whole conversation about and
they were like oh my god i didn't even
think about it like i don't i just say
it so freely
okay well i'm gonna nip it in the bud
now and the n-word is one of those
things like so nobody in your social
circle was like oh that's cringy bro
don't say that
obviously he says it loosely he said it
quite
matter-of-factly so he says it loosely
he's comfortable saying it
he's going to continue to say it i don't
know how i feel about cancel culture
if he can be teachable great i would
love that i would love for him to be
teachable i believe that people can
change and be better i have that type of
faith in humanity
but at the same time i'm like i don't
really know
what's going to change like his core
group is still going to buy the music
he's not going to be technically
cancelled
it just is what it is but if he's going
to you know do some performance
and say he's against the n-word and it's
going to change some people's minds then
great but am i going to listen to morgan
wallin no
right storm says oh lord the i'm sorry
routine nelson says apologies are too
late
he doesn't have the right headset it
looks like he's learning at least
this is the tough spot that morgan is in
like he's you know he's gonna do these
apologies
but the fact is that his sales went up
like all his songs
jumped into the top ten so his fan base
his actual fan base doesn't care and
actually thinks he doesn't need to
apologize so he's gonna be in a weird
spot
that his fans don't think he did
anything wrong which is crazy
but the rest of the world obviously has
their head on straight but so that's the
spot that he's going to be in like in
you know when he's in concerts and stuff
like that
that yeah his fans don't care and
actually
rallied around him and bought his music
which is insane so
yeah he's in a weird spot i'm not sure
how he's going to navigate this going
forward because
probably his fans are going to not want
him you know
to do all this you know this apology to
her so i'm not really sure how he's
going to handle this long term
yeah i mean everybody has like crisis
management or people on their team that
know how to navigate the situation
when his sales and streams go up it says
oh his fan group likes the fact that
he's so controversial likes the
fact that he used the n-word because
they probably are also using the n-word
and they don't give a damn or they want
to support him no matter what or they
think that he's so talented and that
maybe
you know this is a teachable moment they
may they feel sorry for him maybe they
think that he's sincere whatever the
reasoning for
continuing to support him even more post
the situation
for a crisis management person it's like
okay do an apology
so that it looks good but maybe look
like you don't care just a little bit so
your fans don't feel like you've turned
your back on them
like people really sit there in
boardrooms and have these types of
conversations of how to
you know play in the line we saw trump
do it for the last four or five years
playing on the line you know
making it you know it seemed one way but
his core fans know that it's not that
way and they don't believe what he's
selling to the public so
it's just like whatever i'm not
listening to morgan wallin i'm good love
right q says he can't take it back it's
over for him but that's the thing no
it's not even over for him like
sure his his um contract is suspended at
the moment but no his sales are great
he's not fading away like there's
nothing over for morgan while in his
career
his sales is still going well so there's
nothing anything for him to come back to
that he's doing just fine which is crazy
yeah
yeah which is insane it says so much
about the world
yeah america it's insane and i get it i
get it people don't all have to be
cancelled and
you know sometimes people make mistakes
and just because they say certain things
doesn't mean they're actually racist or
doesn't mean
i get all sides of it and i i want to be
fair but
he's just no stranger to controversy
that's what's i mean it's not the first
time he said the n-word so
anyway moving on